hello this is pressed talker in this  video I'm going to present a puzzler  about dividing a shape into four equal  parts I've drawn a trapezoid and the  problem is can you divide the shape into  four equal parts and equal shapes there  are no dimensions given because the  figure is drawn to scale so you can  trace over the figure or you can take a  screen capture and print it out we need  to divide this shape into four equal  parts and four equal shapes  give it a try I'm going to be posting  the solution next Monday  so leave a comment if you got the  solution please subscribe to my channel  you can support me on patreon catch me  on my blog bind your decisions on  Twitter at pressure Walker and you can  get my books listed on my website